your wife Emily got to work with Matt
Damon also a bus Tony yes on The
Adjustment Bureau that movie Adam gets
curious you've probably got to meet him
for the first time then I knew you guys
you know I'm really well now but what
was it like to meet him for the first
time because he was a pretty big Boston
star yeah he's he's a huge deal I think
that for me I graduated high school in
1997 the year that Good Will Hunting
came out so I think every kid from then
on has a Good Will Hunting poster
tattooed to their back so when I got to
meet him I was like oh my god and I was
very excited it was at 30 rock they were
shooting at the top of 30 rock this big
beautiful scene and Emily said come
after four I thought that's really
specific and weird and so I get up there
and this PA yells they're rolling and he
throws me into this black tent and I go
this close to the screen and it's just
Matt and my wife kissing very deeply oh
I thought that's very awkward so then I
go out and I said hey Emily great scene
blah blah and Matt Damon came up and was
just trying to make a joke and instead
he goes hey nice to meet ya I was just
totally tonguing your girl
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and I looked at them and I went okay man
and he just started to melt anyone I'm
so sorry that wasn't funny at all
I'm so sorry I'm like took this day he
can't get over the fact that that's the
first thing he said to me yeah actually
it was funny
you